então hoje eu vim aqui falar com vocês e
dividir um pouco da da minha experiência
eu vim falar sobre a transformação
social através do alimento é eu sou
formado em ciências gastronômicas sou
especialista em gastronomia
mas eu acho que pra gente falar sobre
transformação através do alimento é uma
coisa que eu não há um que acontece do
dia pra noite é uma coisa que vem
às vezes de gerações é uma coisa que às
vezes demanda tempo
então eu gostaria de dividir antes de
começar a falar um pouco da minha
história da minha trajetória com o
alimento gostaria de dividir a história
da minha mãe e da minha vó eu cresci com
quatro pilares
o primeiro deles é se tiver que morrer
que morra de barriga cheia
é verdade que minha mãe ela me ensinou
isso porque minha mãe ela veio do
nordeste para são paulo
ela foi abandonada aqui ela não tinha o
que comer lá veio pra cá e procura de
uma vida melhor e ela chegou aqui ela
foi abandonada e ela também não tinha o
que comer aqui e aí ela sempre me
ensinou isso se eu tiver que morrer que
morra de barriga cheia ea outra coisa
que ela me ensinou é é melhor rir do que
chorar né que muitas vezes a gente cai
pensar nos nossos problemas começa a
chorar entrada uma depressão mais e é
muito melhor do que chorar isso aprendi
com a minha mãe
depois a minha avó minha volta não teve
acesso à escola a escolaridade da minha
avó é lê e escreve o que ela me ensinou
pra viver basta estar vivo e o
conhecimento é o único bem que você tem
que é só seu
e outra coisa que ela me ensinou isso já
na parte de economia que era quem tem um
não tem nada
quem tem dois tem um eu comecei a
trabalhar com 14 anos de idade
lavando peças de carro em uma oficina
mecânica e aí
com 16 anos de idade eu fui trabalhar no
supermercado como empacotador e aí
começa a minha história com o alimento
mas peraí empacotador alimento
com 16 anos eu tive a oportunidade de
entrar no setor de padaria desse mesmo
supermercado e aí eu coloquei na minha
cabeça o seguinte todo mundo precisa
comer é que precisa comer eu acredito
que todos nós precisamos comer não é
verdade
e aí eu falei a essa área a área da
minha vida porque todo mundo precisa
comer eu sempre vou ter pessoas
procurando o meu produto e aí eu comecei
a trabalhar e esqueci o que minha avó me
ensinou que o conhecimento é só meu me
acomodei parei de trabalhar para estudar
e aí o que aconteceu uma eu queria ser
cozinheiro e recebeu um não como você
quer que ser cozinheiro se você não tem
preparação e através dessa não ter a
preparação que eu caí na real falei vou
procurar me qualificar
vou procurar conhecimento foi onde eu
comecei a procurar cursos de gastronomia
é agora a situação melhorou um pouco mas
na minha época um mês de faculdade eram
três meses do meu salário
então como é que eu ia conseguir arcar
com isso
se eu não tinha condições
então comecei a procurar cursos
gratuitos de gastronomia na internet
foi onde
gastrô motivo que a empresa hoje que o
trabalho como coordenador e através do
curso que eu tive de auxiliar de cozinha
eu aprendi que o maior tempero são as
pessoas e valorizar o potencial delas
porque eu estou falando isso
logo depois que terminei esse curso o
fato de não ter condições de pagar um
pouco a minha faculdade não me
desmotivou porque eu sabia que eu teria
chances de conseguir uma bolsa de estudo
e aí tentei bolsas de estudo
ganhei uma bolsa de estudo não pôde
estudar porque a universidade não
aceitava meus documentos meus documentos
não serviam para a universidade
ganhei a segunda bolsa a mesma coisa é
assim
era quase uma humilhação você termos não
aceitarem os seus documentos na terceira
universidade
consegui estudar me formei e aí eu quis
multiplicar o que eu aprendi no meu
curso que eu fiz lá atrás e aí eu entrei
na parte de professor
eu me identifiquei como professor mas
pra mim o professor não é aquela pessoa
que chega e passa a informação o
professor é aquele que dividir o
conhecimento
eu comecei falando não é que o
conhecimento é só nós
quando a gente entende isso a gente não
tem medo de dividir porque por mais que
eu ensinei tudo o que eu sei pra outra
pessoa ela tem um background diferente
ela vai aprender de um modo diferente
ela não vai aprender exatamente o que eu
sei eu dividir com ela o que eu sei e
ela pode mudar aquilo e isso me abriu
portas
comecei a trabalhar como chefe de
cozinha e uma cozinha vegetariana onde
eu descobri as cores dos alimentos onde
eu descobri que você misturando as cores
misturando legumes e vegetais diferentes
você consegue
um prato muito mais bonito você consegue
uma coisa mais saudável e aí que o
efeito é mais contato também com a terra
porque quando se fala de gastronomia
todo mundo pensa em que pensa no prato
final pensando no glamour pensa em toda
beleza mas o que todo mundo esquece é
que o agricultor que estava plantando de
sol a sol
ele é a pessoa mais importante em toda
essa cadeia e isso me abriu portas eu
fui pra europa
eu tive a oportunidade de viver quatro
anos na europa onde eu viajei por mais
de sete países também teve oportunidade
de visitar a índia ea áfrica e o que eu
aprendi ali a primeira coisa quando eu
cheguei na europa foi o shopping todas
as pessoas sentando à mesa conversando
interagindo porque é muito importante
quando a gente fala de alimentação
quando a gente fala de alimento a gente
pensar numa interação entre as pessoas e
ali eu aprendi uma coisa muito
importante
nós pensamos de uma forma que eu vou
usar aqui para exemplificar nós pensamos
de uma forma animal o que seria essa
forma vou explicar o animal ele nasce
cresce e se multiplica e morre
é tudo muito linear você percebe uma
linha e aí eu aprendi eu aprendi percebi
que a gente pode mudar as coisas
pensando o vegetal o que seria pensar o
vegetal uma árvore
as folhas caem as folhas crescem tem o
período de colheita tem o período de que
têm os frutos
se você arrancar um galho ele vai nascer
de novo
nascem outros galhos é uma maneira mais
fica de pensar porque eu estou trazendo
isso hoje porque não existe uma forma de
falar
de transformação através da alimentação
se a gente não enxergar o alimento como
parte do nosso dia a dia
a comida não é aquilo que a gente vai
comer para nos alimentar a comida ela
também tem esse poder de transformar
como eu falei a gente tem que pensar em
todas as fases tem que pensar na pessoa
que está ali plantando tem que pensar na
pessoa que está colhendo tem que pensar
em tudo e eu gostaria de propor agora um
exercício com vocês
eu gostaria que vocês fechasse um pouco
os olhos de vocês e eu queria propor um
lugar
imagine que nós estamos em uma
vizinhança
nessa vizinhança a tony a tonalidade do
ambiente atual é de tonalidade do lugar
é toda puxada por um cinza um tom meio
escuro meio sujo e nessa vizinhança você
tem vários pontos onde tem lixo vários
pontos que são abandonados e nessa mesma
vizinhança tem algumas pessoas que
trabalham que vão ganhar o seu sustento
fora dessa vizinhança que compra um só
alimento fora dessa vizinhança e outras
pessoas que não têm trabalho e aí um
belo dia nesse lugar todo cinza que as
pessoas saem para trabalhar outras ficam
não tem o que fazer durante o dia
chega uma pessoa e decide plantar um
jardim e ele decide plantar uma horta e
àquela hora
tá começa a ser cuidada por todas
aquelas pessoas que não trabalhavam que
ficavam ali e essas pessoas começam a
cuidar dessa horta começam a comer dessa
horta e aí as pessoas que eram nessa
vizinhança e saíam para trabalhar e
compravam as coisas fora e levavam pra
dentro
começam também a comprar o que a
vizinhança está produzindo então a cor
começa a mudar
a gente dá lugar a tira efe cinza e
começa a trazer o verde
a gente começa a trazer um pouco de
relação entre essas pessoas um pouco de
conhecimento entre as pessoas começam a
conhecer umas às outras
e aí você passa a ter uma forma de
economia que vêm de fora pra dentro e de
dentro para dentro
essa é a transformação através do
alimento que eu acredito
uma transformação que vem de dentro que
vai pra fora e volta para dentro porque
muitas vezes a gente pensa nessa questão
do alimento
você pode abrir os olhos agora e eu
queria trazer alguns exemplos práticos
de como você consegue trazer a
transformação social através do alimento
quando eu fui na índia eu conheci um
projeto em escolas que era o seguinte os
pais queriam que os seus filhos comecem
melhor nas escolas públicas o que eles
fizeram decidiram fazer uma horta e aí
ninguém queria foi esta horta
os pais dos alunos fizeram um banco de
sementes e fizeram a primeira horta
depois
fizeram outras hortas no mesmo molde até
que essa volta começaram a ser apoiadas
e se espalharam por toda aquela região
outro exemplo na áfrica
plante uma árvore na escola
como eu falei às vezes há a
transformação pelo alimento ela não é
rápida porque uma árvore
ela precisa as vezes de 10 15 anos para
começar a dar frutos
e esse projeto era isso as pessoas
plantaram uma árvore frutífera em uma
escola para que daí há dez anos as
pessoas que estavam naquela escola as
crianças que estudavam ali poderiam ter
acesso a frutas poderiam ter acesso a um
alimento de qualidade e muitas vezes a
gente esquece dessa questão do que do
tempo tudo na natureza embora seja um
ciclo tem um tempo
as árvores demoram a crescer mas elas
dão frutos a partir do momento que elas
cresceram adão frutos a todo ano toda a
estação
e muitas vezes a gente pensa em resolver
o problema de ontem pra hoje
e aí acaba não fazendo nada que resolva
esse problema a longo prazo ea curto
prazo a gente não consegue resolver ea
mensagem que eu queria passar aqui hoje
é o seguinte que de uma semente a gente
consegue uma árvore uma árvore gera
outras sementes que geram outras árvores
que vão gerar outras sementes e outras
árvores até formar uma floresta
então o que eu queria trazer aqui pra
vocês hoje é uma semente que daqui a
alguns anos possa se tornar uma floresta
obrigado
[Aplausos]